in the rivers of the amazon rainforest
is a fish like no other
[Music]
a fish that you would not want to find
yourself wading in the water with
a specimen of this fish was brought to
philadelphia from south america in 1773.
it was observed that it had the
extraordinary power of communicating a
painful sensation like that of an
electrical shock to the people who
touched it and of killing its prey at a
distance
it was a fish so unusual that it would
go on to change the course of science
and in fact the course of modern society
forever
electric eels are a genus of freshwater
fish from south america famous for their
ability to stun their prey by generating
electricity
eel is a misnomer as they're actually
part of the knifefish family and are
more closely related to catfish than
eels
and though they aren't the only electric
fish in the world they are by far the
most powerful
some individuals are able to deliver
shocks at up to
860 volts and one amp
the average shock from an electric eel
lasts about two thousandths of a second
a single shock likely wouldn't kill a
person but it could seriously stun one
if shocked your muscles would briefly
contract and then you'd feel numb
if you were in the water and got shocked
it could lead to drowning
and not only can the eel use electricity
to stun or kill its prey
it can use electricity to control its
target remotely
the electricity coursing through the
prey's body making it act in a way
detrimental to itself and beneficial for
the eel
and as formidable a hunter as an
electric eel is on its own recent
studies have discovered that they are
not the solitary predators researchers
always believed them to be
they are in fact proficient and
effective pack hunters ambushing schools
of fish in terrifying unison
how is it possible for a fish to
generate so much electricity
and what has modern science learned from
this improbable creature
[Music]
electric eels live in streams flood
plains and swamps of the amazon and
orinoco river basins in south america
such murky habitats can be dangerously
seasonal for a fish
but luckily for the electric eels they
can breathe air thanks to a special
mucous membrane in their mouth that can
absorb
oxygen electric eels are snake-like in
appearance and they are pretty huge
they can grow up to 8 feet or 2.5 meters
in length and weigh as much as 44 pounds
or 20 kilograms
and 80 percent of the eel's body by
length and by weight is dedicated to one
thing
generating ridiculous amounts of
electricity
the electric eel has three pairs of
electric organs that run through the
back portion of its body the sax organ
the hunter's organ and the main organ
the main and hunter's organs are the
high voltage producers used for defense
and for stunning prey
the sax organ is capable only of
producing low voltage pulses its purpose
is mainly electro communication and
navigation
these organs contain hundreds of
thousands of modified muscle cells
called electrocytes
these are flattened disc-like cells that
are stacked in about 70 columns on each
side of the fish's body
in their resting state these
electrocytes maintain a negative charge
as the cells constantly work to pump
positively charged sodium and potassium
ions out
and each electrocyte is connected to the
nervous system but only on one side
when the eel senses prey or a threat it
sends a signal through the nerve endings
causing an ion channel on the
electrocyte to open
extracellular positive ions can then
flow back into the cell
the side without the nerve connection
continues to pump the positive ions out
of the cell
this gives the left side of the cell a
relatively positive charge and the right
side a relatively negative charge and
voila a dipole has been created and the
eel can start zapping
the electric charge flows towards the
eel's head and is then discharged
through the water towards prey
and the more cells that are stacked and
lined up the more electricity they can
generate
because incredibly the eel is able to
open all of its membrane gates at
exactly the same time creating a huge
jolt of electricity this seems like an
extreme ability but it's an ability
based on what typical muscles and nerve
cells already do
all muscle and nerve cells have
electrical potential and a simple
contraction of a muscle cell will
release a small amount of voltage
the cells of an electric eel have simply
amplified that potential
an eel's ability to make electricity is
often compared to a battery and this
comparison is no coincidence
the very first battery invented in 1800
was inspired by the electric eel
italian physicist alessandro volta
observed that electric eels had stacks
of cells that looked a lot like a roll
of coins
he figured if he could mimic this
arrangement he too might be able to
generate electricity
he cut coin-shaped disks from various
dissimilar metals and stacked them
trying to find any combination of them
that would create electricity
eventually he tried copper and zinc
disks and separated the stacked pairs
with salt water
and lo and behold electricity started
flowing
this came to be known as the voltaic
stack and is considered to be the first
electric battery ever made
before this discovery scientists barely
understood static electricity
and the electric eel was only beginning
to reveal its mysteries
scientists soon realized that eels don't
have a one zap fits all policy
they instead are able to use different
charges for different things
some for sensing their environment some
for communicating some for stunning
their prey and even some for controlling
the movements of their prey
[Music]
electric eels can control their
electricity with finesse
in their dark and murky habitat electric
eels can't rely on eyesight for
navigation
in fact their eyesight is extremely poor
they instead use weak electric
discharges around 10 volts to electro
locate
this weak charge emanates from their
body and the eel can detect distortions
in the electric field from objects
either conducting or resisting their
electricity
this weak electric discharge is created
when the eel simply activates only a
subset of its electrocytes
electric eels can even communicate using
low voltage electric pulses
by varying the frequency that they
produce these pulses researchers believe
that eels can convey information about
their sex and reproductive receptivity
and of course eels use their electricity
for hunting
electric eels are mostly nocturnal
they'll wait for darkness and then sneak
up on their prey and unleash a series of
high frequency high voltage pulses
in this video the red frames indicate
when the electric organs are discharging
after just a few milliseconds the prey
is completely
such a high frequency high voltage
attack induces massive whole body muscle
contractions in the prey fish
the electric shock causes the prey
fish's motor neurons and thus their
muscles to become simultaneously
activated
the higher the voltage the more intense
the muscle contraction and at 600 volts
or more these attacks often cause the
maximum possible muscle contraction
causing the animal to completely seize
up
this is similar to how a taser works
then once it's immobilized the eel can
feast
electric eels don't have upper teeth so
they rely on suction to pull the prey
into their mouth before swallowing them
whole
for a long time scientists thought that
eels implemented these two types of
discharge
low voltage for navigation and
communication high voltage for
immobilizing prey
but they soon learned there is more to
the story
and that eels use their electricity in
even more cunning ways
when looking at the timing of the
electric pulses researchers started to
notice an interesting pattern
introduction of prey into the aquarium
arouses the eel causing it to swim
around but often stopping in a
particular corner of the aquarium
during these stops two high voltage
pulses with an interval of about two
milliseconds are emitted
after these two high voltage pulses the
eel takes a pause and then proceeds with
its usual high voltage high frequency
attack volley
these two high voltage pulses are known
as doublets and at first their purpose
wasn't fully understood
why let out two quick pulses initially
if the massive attack volley will be
more than enough to immobilize prey
scientists carefully observed the eel's
behavior and noticed a few things
one a massive attack volley would almost
always come after the doublet
and two the doublets themselves resulted
in a massive whole body twitch in nearby
fish
perhaps the purpose of these doublets
was not to stun the prey but to force
the prey to reveal its location to the
eel
to test this scientists set up a clever
experiment
on one side of an agar barrier they
placed an electric eel
on the other side of the barrier they
placed a dead fish and connected it to
an electrical stimulator
the fish was then sealed in a bag and
electrically isolated from the eel
the scientists could electrically jolt
the fish with their stimulator but the
eel could not
the stimulator was set up so that when
the eel emitted a doublet it would send
a similar shock to the dead fish
when the eels emitted its doublet and
the dead fish received the simulated
doublet the eels immediately responded
to the twitch with a high voltage volley
and strike towards the dead fish
but when the investigators turned off
the stimulator and the eel emitted its
doublet no twitch was produced in the
dead fish and the eel did not attack
the eel would only attack the fish if it
first twitched in response to its
doublet
this study shows that electric eels can
indeed remotely control their prey
forcing them to reveal their location
but what if an eel finds itself near an
entire shoal of fish
a shoal that seems particularly good at
keeping its distance to avoid such
shocks
to deal with this some electric eels
display a remarkable behavior a behavior
unprecedented in the world of electric
fish
social predation where groups of animals
coordinate to hunt and kill prey is a
tactic commonly seen in mammals like
wolves orcas or lions
in fish this behavior is almost unheard
of
so when scientists traveling through the
amazon river noticed groups of eels
sometimes over a hundred of them
seemingly rounding up and attacking prey
together they almost could not believe
their eyes
at dawn and dusk the scientists noticed
an increase in eel activity with many
individuals leaving the murky depths and
swimming near the surface
appearing to congregate
these groups of eels would then swim
together towards a shallow hunting area
that contained thousands of small fish
these groups of sometimes hundreds of
eels would then start to swim in circles
herding the fish into prey balls and
pushing them to shallower water
then between two and ten individual eels
would launch a joint predatory strike
in this video you can recognize the
attacking eels by their synchronized
sinusoidal body posture
the fish hit with the electrical attack
spasm so hard that they jump out of the
water and then return to the surface
stunned and motionless
the eels then quickly eat the fish
the eels would carry out this attack
sequence five to seven times and each
time a different subset of eels would
produce the electrical attack
although researchers weren't able to
measure the voltage of the coordinated
electric attacks they estimate that 10
volta's electric eels working together
could create 8 600 volts this hunting
technique allows the eels to subdue huge
quantities of prey that would normally
be too evasive to capture
and it's not just that these eels were
stuck together in a confined area
forcing them to feed on the same group
of fish
these eels were congregating from far
and wide to repeatedly forage together
over time using communication in the
form of low voltage electric pulses and
body posturing
it's unknown if the eels have any
familial relationship to each other like
is common with many other pack hunters
but scientists are working to find that
out
only nine other species of fish have
ever been observed to hunt together and
the electric eels may be the most
formidable
this shows us that animals we think we
understand can have more than one
survival strategy
that in isolated regions and with
specific groups of animals predator prey
interactions may not be at all what we
expect
one lingering question that may have
come to your mind is how do the eels not
shock each other
it's believed that the electric organ of
an electric eel is padded with adipose
tissue that insulates the fish from its
own electric shocks
but how do they prevent getting shocked
from other eels
the likely answer is that they don't
electric eels are probably pretty huge
for exactly this reason
they're much larger than their prey such
that an eel's current will easily
incapacitate their target but won't do
much to their larger bodies
similarly to how a single electric eel
shock to us would hurt us for a second
but not kill us
to an eel getting shocked is likely just
a part of doing business
an eel's entire world revolves around
its electricity
and largely thanks to the electric eel
so does ours
next time you charge your phone or stick
some double a's in your remote you can
thank the electric eel for its
contribution to our understanding of
electricity
and we continue to be inspired by them
researchers are currently working on an
entirely new type of battery inspired by
eels
a soft and flexible battery that can
power medical implants and soft robots
we are likely just beginning to
understand these incredible creatures
with many more of their mysteries still
lurking in the muddy waters of the
amazon
understanding the electric eel has
ignited a curiosity in me about the
electricity in the world all around us
it's nearly impossible to not take it
for granted i know i certainly don't
often think about how the lights in my
kitchen work how my computer stays
charged or how the grid in texas is
teetering on a knife edge and is doomed
to fail at any moment okay maybe i do
think about that last one but in general
how electricity works is rarely on my
mind but the more i learn the more
incredible it becomes with brilliant
electricity and magnetism course you can
discover the physical laws of
electricity and magnetism that are the
backbone of our modern world
it begins with simple analogies and then
walks you through step by step how
electricity was discovered and slowly
building to explain some fundamental
equations that look complicated but make
total sense when every step is broken
down for you
it's not overwhelming like college
classes can be
and rather than penalize you when you
get an answer wrong it guides you to the
right one with a more in-depth
explanation
there are so many courses to dive into
from neural networks to algorithms to
the physics of every day
and signing up is the single best way
you can support this channel to get
started for free visit brilliant.org
real science or click on the link in the
description and the first 200 people
will get 20 off brilliant's annual
premium subscription and if you're
looking for something else to watch
right now you can watch our previous
video about the mysteries of deep sea
gigantism or watch real engineering's
latest video about self-healing
spacesuits
[Music]